and I get annoyed hearing people talk
endlessly about how we're the worst
country in the world we're the most
sexist country in the world we're the
most racist it's all nonsense this is
one of the best places to live in the
world and that's what we should be
talking about the fact
that shame this is this is exactly this
is exactly the problem that I'm talking
about you are saying shame on you for
talking up Britain and that is exactly
the problem that we're talking about
this is one of the best places to
in the world for minorities like me it's
the best
place there's no point shouting out for
because the people are home can't hear
you so so and also let's not let's try
not hang on let's try not to talk over
each other I asked constant a question
we In fairness I have to let him we've
got to stop we've got to stop talking
down our country we've got and we've got
to stop shouting over people who are
talking 2 minutes left and I have to let
the rest of the panel answer so let me
just do that